how's gum resumes period Pat welcome to
watchdogs this came out today so that
probably means it's gonna be videos of
this crawling all over YouTube but don't
worry I'm gonna make the most fulfilling
the most professional and was serious
the best graphics so don't don't even
bother looking further I need to change
some settings for the quake I play an
old trap because I'm not a [ __ ] and
teenage [ __ ] skin take three hours to
[ __ ] load it says it's still running
for some reasons I have to restart
everything PEGI 18 don't Peggy 18 me oh
yes finally new game
yes alright it's gonna be great told you
this is the most professional I heard
this game is really great graphics and
I'm all about the great graphics that's
why I never played my minecraft because
the graphics are just not up to my
standard of graph graphics true story I
swear
so it takes place in Chicago this game I
never I never been but it looks cool
looks like a good city they picked shut
up [ __ ]
is that our main character disguise
maybe did I tell you to shut up
there's our main character well the [ __ ]
does that where are we stealing all
their money you can see how much money
they have the quarter router secret key
lies floating in a crowd of data I just
reached out plucked from the sky and if
you it's ours
stay focused
we got a nasty security system how much
we got a hundred grand in 30 seconds
god bless the regime things
we are the modern-day magicians
siphoning bank accounts out of people
through your phones my god I better hide
my phone no I think someone else is
happening in let's take a peek
stick to the plan Damian secondly
accountant get out and venture my boy
have faith in your mentor something
triggered by the Lord let's find it I'm
almost there
I'm shutting down now don't you touch a
thing
what the hell is that we need to abort
we're not done tell me Damien it's over
on his
how would they know it's him anyway
we're like why is he running what
happened I don't understand I'm not a
hacker so I possibly could have know
there's this to hackers inside Eden oh
god they know Maurice yeah you're on one
of our contractors ran his search for
the hackers in the Merlotte job your
assigned aiden pearce take him out hit
the family if you need to but it said it
was single looking days are done they
found their noise that's a problem no no
see I'm good
you'll never hear from him again did you
Skype or something uh-huh
so the kids died is that in now he has
to seek revenge roll credits
that's pretty cool though
I'm not gonna lie Viki
so I'm actually gonna lay I don't know
how far we're gonna play this I don't
know if this is gonna be a series but I
wanted to do like I kind of check out
let's look at this game or whatever if
you bros one more I'll give you more in
the button sorry but if not then that'll
be it I don't mind either way who gave
the order
oh where you found the guy
if the family not a problem
no no see I'm good you'll never hear
from him again
uh-oh you've done [ __ ] up now stop it
I didn't know they never gave me a name
can they just come went to his house
like normal people do when they scare
nobody hits alright that wasn't supposed
to happen I want you to think very
carefully think look me even if I know a
name you couldn't get me talking
these guys I heard stories man they like
nothing ever seen before
you got to walk away from this man
there's Tempe a party later
Oh are we gonna murder him
who gave the order I suppose I'm on the
phone they told me where to find him so
I know Jesus don't make yourself now hey
oh all right
ah come on Oh Presby all right
I praise be I did that
took a lot of skill to do that we do now
that won't talk to me but I bet he
talked to you examine Murray's phone
information skills to me SOT thank you
extra hack that's us need to keep moving
now was that we're gonna get anything
out of that pop machine a lot popped so
I can hack as oats really okay all the
sodas are mine this is amazing what else
can I do I can get information on them
by scanning with my iPhone which app is
that I wonder I can pick some meds and I
can go I've y'all Maurice
go shaking [ __ ] oh god you right
away where the hell you been what he's
talking to me
hahahahaha I leave my pants for two
minutes
give me my bullets that's awesome like
you said you'd kill him otherwise
I told you to hold on to the majority so
he was actually gonna shoot him oh I had
to make a call and you get what you need
from Maurice not really kidding me let's
clean this mess up stop admiring your
work hey that's cute and all but I'm
disappointed Pierce
I mean you failed to spot the nasty
inter-gang drama I'm creating here I
don't like loose ends let's get him out
of here
No too late bottom of the eighth
Chicago's ahead games almost over we are
out of time
oh Jesus I shot huh come on you know
just a little interested in my phone
call
all right fine tell me about your phone
call glad you asked okay we got a bunch
of dead bodies right we got 40,000
people above us we need a distraction
I called the cops you need your what oh
yeah true story so cops arrived and
maurices little band of brothers arrived
sources tell me you're joking no no I
called them to look we get a messy
altercation at the end of the game you
and i slip away undetected you'll
appreciate the plan tomorrow ah great
punctual cops handle these guys you grab
more ease get him out of here Maurice
what do I look like a chauffeur he's the
shooter
not through with you owe me a gain all
right dick your haircut is a day and
things it looks like a to cover Fred
speech acts a comer cool I did it I can
spend check great best guy remember 10
out of 10 right we got cops better sneak
around him now there's one there their
corpse another Viceroy oh really
biggest game of traffic
second hack stuff and make noises as
distraction my god what game is it okay
exposes data flow online objects there
we go so I have to follow the line right
yep through the camera Oh Matt that's
well in there what is that we should
check that out later what does it be guy
Oh see anything nothing
that's another camera Oh
33 least I did what about those guys
superhero expert okay I'm coming up what
tell is that even mean we need you down
there make sure we don't get any
surprises all right guess I should Hank
that one can we do it exit all right
cool
and it's open bingo jingling go on this
lingo lingo dingo your dingus he's not
moving unless I give them a reason all
right let's pick up some of these what
do I do those snacks a my robot hold to
open weapon wheel select okay
but I did it ler
press y to craft selecteditem release
okay now we can use it let's throw it
right there and then click X hold X take
the bait I mean who else would just
check out sweet sweet music if it it's
placed in the wall how can it be so
distracted by that seriously my god
you're dumb alright let's go are you sir
okay business manager mister guard we're
just talking hemophobia
no keep your hands where I can see
homeboy djinji do nothing wrong get back
now your vice was aren't you oh no I
forgot the Bangor smart how did you two
afford VIP ticket bet she makes more
than you do
hey yo lady you can find in for about
everyone that's pretty awesome
which wish I could be Susie's that in
real life
bad boy now guide please for about the
lock this whole place down I'm stuck
unless we create major destruction I
want to cuddle our Miss Lee passed
through an old failure I thought he
wanted to keep the future a battle my
synergy everything's good acted you to
see to us with serious firewall right
now I need to get out of the stadium can
you find me the nearest access point if
it makes true well you need to find
someone with security clearance security
got you have access all these cops
there's gotta be one around
so we have to find highschool bully
that's like okay let's find a security
guy 40,000 people so we can play cowboys
and Indians huh means yeah this whole
boys about to fill up with Chicago PD
that's gonna cause a panic we need to
shut the game down and get people out of
here safely I can make that call I need
to hack our chefs with that fresh table
dining oh my god
okay I better hurry where is it never
again
I'm tagged the door and oh it's another
camera oh this is how I can works in
real life then why doesn't not everyone
do it oh hello
say goodbye to your game suckers Sports
is for nerds real badasses they play
video games that's a bad thing
oh Jesus
I better get out of here breasts they
never do it hidden
how do I run though there we go
thanks games appreciate it wait what was
that oh god I can't use it because of
the blackout now all right I think we
did pretty good have five little bit why
are you Geordi but gone I'm allergic to
cops
those worries but don't worry I left you
a present friend of a friend deals in
pre-owned cars got a real beauty waiting
for you the garage across the street is
you're leaving I don't care
gotta go so we get a car sweet rad baby
banned from cinema what the hell did he
do faff in it recently adopted by a dog
oh god what's going on oh why am I stuck
on oh my my controller something and
that's an accident like what the foot
now it won't work again got a switch to
mouse and keyboard for [ __ ]
gonna jump here oh yeah cool single
parent what a loser I'm joking I'm sorry
you're a single parent watching this
don't be offended you're not a loser
you're super cold okay let's go in here
the volume went down like massively as
well what the [ __ ] is going on with this
computer [ __ ]
alright anyway alright let's go [ __ ]
oh god we better not attract attention
let's not attract traffic lights whoa
let's take a shortcut baby yeah ain't
nobody noticed that [ __ ] finally got the
goddamn trigger man just need to break
through
pushed more he's hard Richard hi guys
work on this guy so I need to get inside
his head
guilt is eating him up I'll give him a
couple of days I bet he'll start
reaching out so we're gonna hack his
brain now
it's got whoo yeah oh sorry about that
good thing we took measurements to avoid
police earlier cuz otherwise we might be
in trouble right now
gone watch where you're going oh the
Alamo tell of it
sorry bout that barked and done and we
are ready to go party almost there baby
oh I woke up like the else there we go
come on
no one will ever know where I am
I heard stories rather than nothing ever
seen before I walk away from this thing
why are you sitting here
not like last time no no Jackson I did
invite him it's depressing alone are you
sure you called right number honey your
uncle's a different kind of person it
doesn't mean he doesn't love us
who is the [ __ ]
Hey time Jesus
all right so what do we do now let me
hack my own [ __ ] we gained access to the
CPU is back door while the police were
being distracted by you since we broke
within this we'll share what we have
that back door allows you some access to
the CTU s network I've been working on
something bigger give me time all right
we got some parts and we go to bed let's
pick up at 6:00 and sleep with that
clothes on didn't even brush his teeth
Pawnee okay you were the boss go to plan
not so he was with them in the car
Jesus
oh so that was his daughter
SiC and remember in that way it's never
dream for tinyface pressing the window
when she knows I was coming over when
that little wobbly dance she didn't it's
always the same nightmare
it's dark man that's dark okay there we
go
odds bright and shine any get my mind
off things
lucky for me the city's full of
distractions they can't hide from me
frequently watches police shows he's
blinding a cruise I could renew all this
Shane Facebook
is that it [ __ ] you chair profile people
for potential crimes near your hideout
okay
God why does everyone so [ __ ] nice
where's all the [ __ ] what's up
ladies you don't own the sidewalk oh yes
I do I make me hack your ass right you
know what [ __ ] I own the sidewalk what
is she doing why is she still moving
she's supposed to be dead that thank you
okay volunteers as nude month hello okay
this one is police record let's hack his
ass control you I'm not gonna let hurt
anyone today simple trace of his call
and he's mine what do we do you need
something
okay so that's a crime area potentially
over here we better take care of it
there it is he's after this guy's close
I can feel it
so what do i do then hey we need to talk
you guys nothing to talk about
we're done deal with the [ __ ] wrong
I've not done yet
I gotta stop him now oh god he's gonna
hurt her
I'm the hacker hero oh I got to stop him
you ain't going nowhere [ __ ] you
can run but you can't hide how did that
not kill him he's learning how to read
not on my watch hahaha
god damn ease fast or am i slow I think
I'm slow down [ __ ]
don't you dare learn how to read
[ __ ] but that will make it think
twice about it you won't bother anyone
now because he's dead alright we did it
high five belugas all right friends I
gotta have time that episode there I
hope you enjoyed watching let me know if
you want more or not I'll leave this one
up to you otherwise I'll just play by
myself but I enjoyed playing it I hope
you had fun watching it go ahead and
even like if you want more and let me
know and I'll see Bruce whatever else we
do say awesome love you